- How do they react to you in public?
- I mean, usually, Kate!
- And you're like, that's not my name!
- I'm like, that's not
my name, right exactly.
(laughter)
It's Chrissy, but hi!
- It's a good song.
- Yeah it is.
- Ting Tings, I got you, all right.
- But I often end up crying in bathrooms
with these strangers who
just divulge their most,
deepest, darkest secrets.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Which is so lovely 'cause
that's why I wanted to act
was to like relate to someone.
And so that is wonderful.
But you know, like, one
woman like bum-rushed me
and literally sopping wet cheek kiss.
- Mmm.
- [Chrissy] And I was like, oh.
- I don't do face kiss.
- I was, like, I don't know you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(laughter)
- And you don't know me.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And I might have germs.
- And like, where's your mouth been, girl?
(laughter)
Yeah.
- So, while I appreciate it so much,
sometimes it's like, whoa.
- Yeah, well just so you know,
just a, like, little announcement,
hugs are fine.
- Yeah.
You don't have to kiss.
- A little fist bump.
- You don't have to kiss.
- A little elbow .
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I wasn't gonna tell you, when
people come in on my face,
I'm like, that's for my man.
I don't know you.
- [Chrissy] How 'bout that?
How 'bout that?
That's for my man.
- Yeah.
(applause)
I'm a really nice person.
I will sit and talk to you for an hour
but please don't kiss my face.
- [Chrissy] Yeah.
It can be a lot.
- One thing I love about you to though is
I know that you're a
beautiful and talented actress
but, at the same time,
I know that auditioned
for "American Idol" 'cause
we talked about this
in pilot, but I found out
though that you love music
almost more than acting.
It's a different kinda connection for you.
- Yeah, I think music for me
was something that I grew up
listening to and, like,
you don't need an audience
to perform music.
Like you can sing in your bedroom
And so I would, like, record
myself on little boom boxes.
And music helped and healed so much.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- [Chrissy] Right.
I know that you know, so
for me, it was sort of
my first love.
And then I was like, oh well.
I didn't even think I was
gonna be singing on the show.
It was one of those things
that sort of happened
out of the blue.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, oh
okay and they were like,
if you can't sing, don't, you know.
But it was, like, two of
my worlds colliding like,
dreams, and I was, like, what?
- What a beautiful scene.
That's exciting.
- Yeah, I've always loved music.
- Two of your super powers.
You're getting to do at once.
(imitating trumpet)
(cheering)
Cape flying!